pensemos en exponentes de unos y menos
unos empecemos por ejemplo con 1 elevado
a la potencia no seríamos 8 ok lo que
hemos dicho que esto significa es tomar
8 de estos unos entonces poner por aquí
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y multiplicar los que
tenemos uno por uno por uno por uno por
uno por uno por uno por uno
esto es lo que significa uno elevado a
la 8 sin embargo pues tenemos aquí uno
por uno es uno por uno también es uno y
así no importa cuántos unos tengamos por
aquí uno por uno por uno por uno por uno
por uno por uno por uno por uno siempre
termina siendo igual a uno entonces en
realidad no importa si tenemos aquí uno
elevado a la un millón 955 mil
tengamos aquí muchísimos unos y los
multiplicamos siempre nos va a quedar
uno ahora qué pasa si tomamos el 1
y lo elevamos a la potencia a cero a ver
a ver pues ahora si es necesario
utilizar nuestra segunda definición de
los exponentes y aquí lo que dijimos en
el vídeo pasado es que esto lo que
significa es que tomamos un 1 y lo
multiplicamos por este número
esta cantidad de veces aunque entonces
aquí tenemos que multiplicar el 1 por 10
veces así es que en realidad no lo
tenemos que multiplicar entonces nos
queda simplemente un 1 bueno tal vez
sería bueno recordar esta definición con
otro exponente que no sea el 0 entonces
vamos a elevar al 2 a la potencia 4
porque eso no lo hemos hecho y eso es
igual esto lo que significa es que
tomamos un 1 y lo multiplicamos por este
2 4 veces entonces aquí tenemos que
poner un 2 por otro 2
y otros dos por
el cuarto 2 y 1 x 2 x 2 x 2 x 2 y esto
es igual a la vera que es igual es igual
a 16 aunque esa es la otra forma en la
que definimos estos exponentes y por eso
es que cualquier número que sea distinto
de 0 elevado a la 0 es igual a 1 porque
lo que hacemos es tomar un 1 y
multiplicar por ese número 0 veces o sea
que nos queda simplemente ese número
ahora algo importante que no había dicho
hasta este momento es que este número
tiene que ser distinto de 0 que eleva el
0 a la 0 potencia todavía está en debate
si deberíamos de definirlo como 1 como 0
pero bueno eso no importa por el momento
así es que vamos a ver otros escenarios
muy interesantes por ejemplo vamos ahora
a elevar
1 a la 0 eso es igual a pues como
estamos definiendo lo es un 1 por menos
10 veces o sea que en realidad no
estamos multiplicando al 1 por nada más
así es que nos queda simplemente el 1
ahora vamos con menos 1 elevado a la
potencia 1 y eso es igual a 1
1 x menos 1 una sola vez pero menos uno
por uno el uno no cambia el valor de
cualquier cosa a la cual está
multiplicando entonces esto es igual a
menos 1 y a ver a ver ahora vamos a
elevar al menos 1 a la potencia 2 y eso
lo que significa es que vamos a tomar un
1 y lo vamos a multiplicar por menos 12
veces y eso es igual a haber uno por
menos uno es menos uno y luego por menos
uno es menos por menos nos da más así es
que aquí tenemos simplemente un
aunque ella era muy importante aunque
estemos usando esta definición en la que
primero tomamos un 1 y después
multiplicamos a ese 1 por este número la
cantidad de veces que nos diga el
exponente esta definición es equivalente
a la que teníamos desde el principio
podemos tomar simplemente dos de estos
menos unos y multiplicarlos y nos va a
quedar exactamente lo mismo
ok porque este uno a la hora de estarlo
multiplicando no afecta en lo más mínimo
a estos dos términos bay uno por
cualquier cosa es igual a esa misma
cualquier cosa así es que seguimos y
ahora queremos elevar a menos uno
a la tercera potencia y eso es igual a
11 x menos 1
tres veces
aunque ya están los tres menos uno que
es igual a menos uno por menos uno es
uno por menos uno es menos uno y por uno
pues sigue siendo menos uno entonces
menos
y aquí ya se ve muy claramente cuál es
el patrón no o sea tenemos menos 1 al
acero eso es simplemente un 1 luego
multiplicamos por menos 1 para obtener
menos 1 a la 1 y entonces tenemos menos
1 y luego otra vez multiplicamos por
menos 1 para obtener menos 1 a la 2 y
pues menos 1 por menos 1 es 1 entonces
tenemos un 1 otra vez y luego otra vez
para obtener menos 1 a la 3 tenemos que
multiplicar este 1 por un -1 y entonces
nos queda otra vez menos 1 entonces se
ve claramente el patrón pues resulta que
si el exponente es un número impar
para
entonces vamos a obtener un -1 ok 1 es
un número impar entonces aquí tenemos
menos 13 es un número impar entonces
aquí tenemos un -1 y si tenemos un
exponente par como el 2 entonces vamos a
obtener un 1 gay par nos lleva a un 1
por qué pues porque menos por menos nos
da más y cuando tenemos un exponente par
entonces vamos a tener todas las
parejitas completas y vamos a tener
menos por menos damas por otro menos por
menos que es un más y entonces más por
más y más y así todo va a ser un más
aquí podemos ver otro ejemplo de un
exponente par podemos poner menos 1
elevado a la cuarta potencia eso es
igual a pues 1 x menos 1
cuatro veces y eso es igual a menos 1 x
menos uno que es simplemente un 1 menos
1 x menos uno es 1 y este menos 1 por
menos uno es uno entonces uno por uno
uno
entonces como 4 está aquí lo que tenemos
es un 1 entonces si alguien llega y te
pregunta cuánto vale el 1 elevado a la
potencia un millón y está nuestro millón
esto como ya vimos por acá es
exactamente igual a 1 cierto porque uno
por uno por uno por uno por uno por uno
por uno por uno por uno por uno y así
hasta un millón de veces una es igual a
uno ahora por otro lado si llegan y te
preguntan lo mismo pero con menos 1 o
sea si te preguntan cuánto vale menos 1
elevado al un millón
la potencia un millón pues esto a ver a
que es igual esto pues tomamos el
exponente que es un millón y podemos ver
que este exponente es para entonces esté
menos 1 al a un millón tiene que ser
exactamente igual a 1 ahora sí llegan y
te preguntan cuánto vale menos 1 elevado
a la potencia 999.999 esto como 999.999
es un número impar entonces esto es
igual a menos 1